Speaker 1: This is a very sort of surprising
way to start today's show. But there is now
speculation that Donald Trump is in Washington,
D.C. and may be getting arrested or indicted
imminently. Now it is speculative, but the
speculation is based on a previously unannounced,
seemingly last minute trip that
Donald Trump made to Washington, D.C.
last night. Newsweek reporting Donald
Trump's surprise visit to Washington, D.C.
sparks arrest speculation. Trump made a
surprised and unannounced visit to D.C. Sunday,
prompting speculation and rumors about the
reason for his trip. The video of Trump
arriving at Dulles Airport in Virginia, an airport
frequently used by those heading to the capital,
was posted online by freelance reporter Andrew
Leyden. Trump can be seen getting out of a plane,
heading into a vehicle. Trump appears to be
wearing golf shoes and a white polo top. Now
we're getting into details that seem so trivial,
but there have already been counterpoints that it
appears to be a golf his golf shoes, but those
are not actually shoes. Trump wears the golf.
And thus the idea is he is not just showing up to
golf or necessarily coming from the golf course,
but Trump does stay at his golf courses when
he travels around, if there's one available.
And the motorcade then is believed to have
gone in the direction of one of Trump's golf
courses. Now there is video of what took place,
and there are a number of very strange things
in the video. We're going to play it. See if
you can spot some of them. Then I'll mention
a couple of things that I notice and that others
have noticed as well. We see Donald Trump coming
off the plane holding something not totally clear
what he is holding and getting into a vehicle.
Speaker 2: Is making its way off.
Speaker 1: And then this is at 6:31 p.m..
And then they drive away. One of the really,
really strange things that was pointed out
is that it sort of looks like Trump is carrying
a bottle of ketchup. A bottle of ketchup,
which is an extraordinarily strange thing for a
president, former president to be carrying. But
it might be something else, could be a MAGA hat
folded up or who knows what it is. So there's a
couple of different things going on here. First of
all, do we really know why he's in D.C.? We don't.
Do we know that it is an unexpected and
unplanned trip up until the last moment?
We do because there generally is awareness of the
soon to be whereabouts of the former president.
One explanation would be some kind of
medical issue. Certainly a possibility,
a second possibility. He's he's back to be
reinstated as president of the United States.
Not one I believe is likely, but there are already
the sort of. Q people and conspiracy people
that are speculating along these lines already.
And number three is that it has something to do
with the federal investigation against him, for
he's in there in the city for meetings that were
previously undisclosed based on who knows what is
going on. Okay, fine. This is strange. There are
a number of strange things here. And for people
who understand sort of protocol and the amount
of information that is known ahead of time about
where Donald Trump plans to be, this is certainly
unusual now for those who are continuing to
have this idea of the perp walk, the perp walk
that at some point may happen if Donald Trump is
indicted. I don't think it makes sense to hold
our breaths for that. As I've said before, every
indication that if indeed Donald Trump is going to
be indicted, that there is going to be a sort of
coordinated handoff involving Secret Service and
that there is not going to be the perp walk that
many of us admittedly would love to see of Donald
Trump at some point in time. But no shortage
of the conspiracy people immediately jumping
to he is back to be declared president by, I don't
know, the newly anointed King Charles the third or
who the hell knows what. That is not what
Donald Trump is in Washington, D.C. for.
You now know everything that is known to us as of
this moment and by the time today's episode goes
live, by the time this clip gets up on YouTube and
Facebook and elsewhere, since it takes a couple
of hours for us to turn the show around, there may
be more known and we will then follow up about it.